welcome to my humble abodes
she was a prop from a porno film that we
somehow got our hands on She's Always a
conversation starter this is basically a
gift I simply cut out of the table when
I was top of the Fantasy Premier League
no this was bought at a local Billiards
shop I realized at some point that I
didn't actually have a chess board then
again we're promoting something that's
online and mostly chess is online and
also my my head usually eat when you're
playing long terms sometimes I'll order
Thai or Chinese or something along that
sort and then I'll just use the 50
minutes in between games to eat as much
as possible here is the bathroom where
everything is clean blah blah blah but
you got this this roll up it can be a
little bit dark in here and the desk is
a little bit too too small so there
there's some work to be done